we will be
[Applause]
the freedom Convoy returned to Ottawa
but this time demonstrators were forced
to walk to Parliament Hill Wellington
Street remains closed to traffic and
that led to a smaller more subdued
protest I live here in Ottawa and I
actually miss the sound of the horns
those blaring horns
have been replaced by music
protesters gathered for what they dubbed
a dance party under a heavy police
presence this is anniversary a
celebration of something we've we've
achieved Public Health restrictions may
be gone but the anger against prime
minister Justin Trudeau is not I'd like
to see a change of government but that's
not going to happen today or tomorrow
and I understand that I just like to see
less division within our country we are
as poor we laugh at the United States
we're no different right now
those divisions were on display hey hey
come here a counter protester clashed
with a member of the freedom Convoy a
big bunch of whiny babies
who threw a mega tantrum last year in
our city the crowd gathered on
Parliament Hill at the same time the
liberal caucus was meeting behind us in
West block some of the protesters here
say they would still like prime minister
Justin Trudeau to meet with them and
hear their concerns Trudeau is
acknowledging the frustration I think
responsible leadership is acknowledging
the concerns and anger that people are
feeling and look to solve for look to
provide Solutions look to reassure
people not to amplify that anger the
conservatives are also holding their
caucus Retreat I think we need to
actually look into all aspects of the
pandemic and how it was handled things
are being looked at including the
federal government's use of the
emergencies act the findings are due
next month while some of the main
protest leaders are facing charges
political experts predict the current
climate of polarization is here to stay
the fire was already going and the
pandemic was an accelerant along those
lines so so the disc course I think has
been changing for quite a while and that
discourse may be a preview of what to
expect during the next session of
parliament teria Israeli Global News
Ottawa
[Music]